[Music]
Cynthia Arivo is back in the news. A
couple of months ago, she uh well, it
was announced that she was going to play
Jesus. I'm not going to like this
conversation. She was going to play
Jesus for the new Jesus Christ Superstar
movie on Broadway, which is interesting.
Um, you know, she is a a queer person.
and she is a woman and and uh you know
she played a witch in Wicked also you
know with the the movie but then like
the musical was also on Broadway and now
she's playing in Broadway to play Jesus
but Billboard dropped an article today
where Cynthia Ariva responds to the
criticism that she's had um about
playing Jesus as you know having played
a witch before and being queer and all
that kind of stuff. She plays Jesus and
she says Ario can't help but laugh. Why
not? She chuckles with a shrug before
adding that most of those comments don't
seem to understand the critical lens of
the Andrew Lloyd Weber musical. You
can't please everyone. It's legitimately
a three-day performance at the Hollywood
Bowl where I get to sing my face off. So
hopefully they will come. They will come
to the Jesus Christ Superstar musical
and realize, oh, it's a musical, the
gayest place on earth. I think it's sad
that they don't recognize that, you
know, in the wake of like nobody likes
to be made fun of, right? I mean, they
will go to to bat tooth and nail like
not to have people say ill things
against them, but then they'll go and
they'll they'll do something like this
that I think is completely offensive to
people who who are really Christian.
Yeah. I guess what I wonder cuz I don't
know, I haven't seen it. Is Jesus Christ
Superstar meant to be an evangelistic
tool or is it meant to be more like a
mockumentary?
I think that's the point. Yeah, cuz when
it says, "Oh, she's been receiving
backlash from conservative Christians."
I'm just here thinking it wasn't made
for them anyways. Yeah. I guess they
shouldn't expect anything.
But still, I mean, you don't It doesn't
mean you have to take a step further and
get, you know, if it's done in satire.
Yes. But I've never seen satire of like
Muhammad in a tutu and dancing around in
like No, no. I'm saying if it's if it's
a satire, I mean, would do you really
expect anything but the worst? I see
what you're saying. Yes. No. I I I
probably that's why it's really too
shocking that this would happen. So, you
know, I I get why Christians are
outraged, but they should be outraged
from the beginning no matter who it is.
Like, it doesn't it doesn't even
matter what they're saying. Yeah. like
her playing it doesn't make it
necessarily worse just because the whole
concept is but it's like every time
they're trying to like up a level
they're trying to make it more edgy I
get it definitely yeah well Keith you
actually made a good point and uh you're
headed in the right direction where with
the question is it even supposedly um a
Christian outreach tool to begin with
because no it's not I watched it as a
kid I watched a movie my mom at that
point had kind of left the church but
always still believed but actually
didn't really know God that well and she
showed the movie to me and she even
asked me later on do you want to go see
the musical and I was like well I
believed in God but wasn't really a
Christian wasn't really interested but I
genuinely thought this movie was
supposed to be a Christian movie and
that's kind of the perception I got of
Jesus as a child right and we'll take a
look at a couple of those clips in just
a second but again it started as
obviously a musical so this is a book
written by Scott Miller he's a prominent
figure in American musical theater,
renowned for his role as the founder and
artistic director of New Line Theater in
St. Louis, Missouri. Um, and so he wrote
a book called Sex, Drugs, Rock and Roll,
and Musical Musicals by Scott Miller.
The fact that he wrote this book and
then like includes Jesus Christ
Superstar should be alarming. Tells you
something about It's definitely a clue.
Yeah. But he wrote this book to kind of
show you how musicals really are a
mirror of societal issues and what
society is currently like and then it
shows you how things are becoming more
and more edgy which really explains why
Cynthia Orivo is playing Jesus. It's
just a reflection of society. But so um
in his book he writes about the director
of the first musical Rice. Rice says he
was first inspired by the lyric from Bob
Dylan's song with God on our side. I
can't think for you. You'll have to
decide. Did Judas Escariat have God on
his side? Rice was quoted at the time
saying, "We need to humanize Christ
because for me, I find Jesus as
portrayed in the Gospels as a god, as a
very unrealistic
figure." So, this is what it's about,
right? Yeah. I think it's somebody
that's that really doesn't understand
like the amazing thing that God did came
from heaven in the best place to come
down and live through this
experience you know basically
identifying himself with this little
cockroach in the universe basically and
what a beautiful thing and they're
making fun of that is I mean is it that
they didn't understand because if Dylan
is the one that was basically like you
know at a crossroads.
Yeah. I mean, he's I mean, it's not like
the devil, but Yes. And so, I I don't
know. I think it's just it's um a
teaching moment because he's raising the
question in song and lots of people are
going to listen to that. You can read
the Bible and you know Jesus is on
everybody's side. Mhm. That's why he
died. But unfortunately, I think these
things are put out to try and and and
just mess people up. Yeah. It's like
throwing a little, you know, monkey
wrench in the in the conversation and
and absolutely you don't leave the
feeling of watching these movies. It's
like, wow, I really want to get to know
Jesus. I mean, it reminds me of the
story when Moses was up at Mount Si to
receive the Ten Commandments and the
people down at the base of the Mount
camp, they're like, "Well, Moses has
been gone. We haven't heard from God.
Let's, you know, create something
physical, a God for us." And this is
like, yeah, Jesus doesn't seem real
enough. Let's humanize him. At least
he'll feel real. That's a good point.
You know, it's like they want something
to look real so that they can like Jesus
they can see, connect with in a way, but
it's really the total opposite from what
God is supposed to be. I wonder though
if you could actually like have a
picture, a window into how many people
have actually watched it and maybe like
walked away from God as opposed to has
anyone watched it and been brought to
God. It's a that's a good question.
That's a really good question. And you
know, as I watched some of these clips
again of Jesus Christ Superstar, the
movie, of which I'm about to show you, I
was like, I don't think it would have
brought me closer to God back then when
I didn't know much about God. And then I
watched this. But we'll take a look at
that in just a second. But, you know, he
goes on in his book saying, "The same is
true on the other hand for Judas, who is
portrayed just as a sort of cardboard
cutout figure of evil." He's referring
to the movie Jesus Christ Superstar here
or the musical. Strangely, the bulk of
American and British critics complained
repeatedly that this was not a proper
retelling of the biblical story of
Christ. And the respected British
director Peter Hall said, "I think Jesus
Christ Superstar says nothing about
Christ and nothing for or against
religion." I But I but I think it's kind
of a silly thing to say because you're
like, uh, you called it Jesus Christ
Superstar. It's about the guy that
you're talking about, you know, and use
the same scenes. Yeah. Call him
Blueberry Man from the Muffin Hill, you
know? It's like you don't have to like
use Christianity. And it's not only
that. Jesus was known for his actions as
well. Uh not only for his words, not
only for the the the sermon on the
mount. So when you put someone named
Jesus Christ, and I haven't seen the
musical or any of the clips, but I'm
assuming he did not act like Jesus or
Christlike. So when you put someone like
named Jesus and act however they act,
how do you think people are going to
think that Jesus acts? Yeah. And they
have a Judas character. So what are you
supposed to think? Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. It is what it is. They have
disciples and everything. Yeah. You know
the last part here. Of course they were
exactly right. But they hadn't
understood that this was the creator's
intention all along. Rice and Lloyd
Weber never intended to tell the
biblical story, but instead an
alternative story of famous events. And
that and what's more, they were telling
the story of Judas, not Jesus.
Wow. But is Judas the hero or is Well,
they they kind of see him as like this
anti-hero where, you know,
he in the movie at least, they seem to
portray him as someone who really
struggles with his emotions and you
should have a little bit of sympathy for
him.
kind of like the whole sympathy for the
devil idea. I mean, didn't Jesus say, "I
have not lost one, but the son of
predition and speaking about Judas." So,
I mean, it's like, you know, the one
character that, you know, probably and I
don't know, you know, if you have direct
evidence that that that that he's not
going to be in heaven, which I don't
think he is going to be, right? Doesn't
seem like it. Doesn't seem like he's
going to be. So making him the prominent
storyteller over the character that it's
actually supposed to be about is Jesus
is I think another slam. That's a dig.
Yeah. And I I do remember seeing
throughout the movie now that I saw some
of the clips and remember you know what
I was watching at the time that Yeah.
Judas is there the whole time, you know,
and he's constantly like taking a jab at
Jesus. Why do you do this? Why do you do
that? Why not this? You're not very
smart, are you? Like kind of like that.
It's it's just another like has been
hotel. Yeah. Yeah. True. It's all it is,
you know. Yeah. It's I want to live my
life the way I want to live it. I don't
want God to judge me. I still expect him
to take me to heaven and he's a jerk if
he doesn't. Yeah. Mhm. And but you know
what's going to be so sad is when that
day happens and the realization of
people like this that are just like,
"Wow, I traded eternity for for what?
For this to poke a little fun at this
guy to sing for 3 hours." Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yeah, for fame and money really. And uh
yeah, like you said, just to poke fun at
him. So, uh Jesus Christ Superstar. I
remember vividly seeing this DVD cover.
In fact, I think I remember actually
that it was in my high school's library
and I took it home and I was like, "Mom,
look at this." You know, same with
Passion for the Christ of the Christ. Um
and uh yeah u this was my first sort of
m movie introduction to Jesus. Oh, and
by the way, before we look at a couple
of these clips, Jesus Christ Superstar
was shot in the 70s. And so, the way
they did retell it, I guess you could
say, is that people are dressed in 70s
clothing and you'll see the Sadducees
and Pharisees standing on scaffolding
instead of standing on like the walls of
Jerusalem, like that kind of stuff. So,
gotcha. It's a retelling. So, uh, let's
take a look at a couple of clips. Again,
it's wild to me that I watched as a kid
and I look back and I'm like, whoa, I
think I was pretty
[Music]
indoctrinated. Try not to get worried.
Try not to turn onto problems that upset
you. Don't you know everything's all
right? Yes, everything's fine and we
want you to sleep well
tonight. Let the world turn without you
tonight. If we try, we'll get by. So,
forget all about us tonight.
Everything's all right. Yes.
Everything's all right. Yes. Sleep and I
shall soothe you. come you and anoint
you for your hot
forhead. Then you'll feel everything's
all right. Yes, everything's fine and
it's cool and the ointment
sweet for the fire in your head and
feet. Close your eyes. Close your eyes
and relax. Think of nothing
tonight. All right. Yes. Right. Yes,
everything is fine and it's cool and the
ointment
sweet for the fire in your head and
feet. Close your eyes. Close your eyes.
Close your eyes and
relax. Close your eyes. Close your eyes
and Okay, so this is this is uh Mary
Magdalene here. Um she becomes a
follower of Jesus. That's what the Bible
says. In this case, she's singing a song
to Jesus. And this was a lot of the
criticism that the conservative
Christians had back in the day. They're
like, "It looks like Mary Magdalene is
in love with Jesus." You know, like,
which I I mean, the the apocry Bibles,
the books, the missing books apparently
do have Jesus and Mary Magdalene. Yeah.
Um or married or have kids or something
like that. Yeah. They had some type of
relationship. That's weird. So, and I
think those books are still included in
some Bibles uh today. So, I think the
Yeah, the Catholic uh Bible has still
the seven Apocryph books included in it.
I thought there was an early King James
that had that. What?
I don't know about the King James, but I
know the Catholic Bible still has 73
books instead of 66, which includes the
love story or some type of relationship
between Mary and Jesus. I I just find it
so weird because you know the Bible says
nothing about this. Nothing. It says
nothing nothing about Jesus having
relationships with anybody. And and to
me it's feels offensive because you know
Jesus is God. But when you heard the the
author of the book writing about his
perception of Jesus Christ Superstar,
you know the the directors were like we
want to make him look more like man.
Well, then obviously they'll put in
their sexual temptation. But Jesus
overcame everything and he is God. He's
not going to go and have relationships
with his creation, you know. Yeah. I
wonder what's going to happen with the
new one with Cynthia Revo. It's going to
be a bunch of men around her. Or is
Jesus going to be a male? It might be a
bunch of women. I mean, it I mean, why
not? Yeah, she's queer and she preaches
about That's a good question. That's
That's just gets really weird right
there. And then, you know, I don't know
if you guys picked up on some of the
women here are half naked. They're all
like touching him on his face and his
arms and his chest. And it looks really
weird to me. Like, I would not just
touch anybody like that. But it's just
like, you know, if my husband, my face
is that close, I might touch his face
like that. I'm not going to just do that
to some Okay, never mind. It is really
weird. So there is another clip here
where you see this is the the Jesus
Christ Superstar musical. This one came
out I don't know couple years ago and
you see they do the same
thing and we want you to sleep well
tonight without you
tonight. If we try we'll get by. Don't
forget all about us tonight.
Everything's all right. Yes.
Everything's all right. Yes. Sleep and I
shall soothe you, calm you and anoint
you. Move for your heart, forehead. Oh,
then you feel everything's all right.
Yes, everything's fine and it's cool and
the ointment
sweet for the fire in your head and
so you can see like to me this looks
really sensual and he's just like Yeah.
Yeah. You know, it's just it's just
adding a sort of just demeaning
derogatory, you know, sort of flavor to
Jesus. Absolutely. And what is the song
about? Is like she's giving him some
like ointment. Yeah. Comfort ointment
like for his forehead. Yeah, that's what
it's about. So So this song though in
the movie is I would say even more so
adding that that idea that they were in
a relationship and that she's in love
with him. So listen to the lyrics, but
I'll also have it spelled out on the
screen after. It's pretty wild.
I don't know how to take
this. I don't see why he moves
me. He's a
man. He's just a man.
And I've had so
many men
before in
very
many
ways. He's just one
more. Should I bring him down? Should I
scream and shout? Should I speak of
love? Let my feelings out. I never
thought I'd come to
this. What's it
all
about?
Yet if he said he loved
me, I'd be lost. I'd be
frightened. I couldn't
cope. Just couldn't
cope. I'd turn my
head. I'd back away. I
wouldn't want to
know. He scares me
so. I want him
so. I love
him.
So, okay. So, let me read out the lyrics
for you guys. Right. So, it says, "I
don't know how to take this. I don't see
why he moves me. He's a man. He's just a
man. I disagree. We'll look at scripture
in just a second. And I've had so many
bad so many men before in very many
ways. He's just one more. So, wait a
minute. You were a prostitute before and
now you're saying, "Well, in very many
ways, he's just one more that I have
been with." Yeah. It's like putting him
on the level of just like all these
other men that are doing these
debaucherous things and he's just one
more guy like that. I think it depends
on the perspective from which it's
written though. If you're taking this as
like a, you know, I don't know what
point this is in the story line, but if
she's looking at it from an early
perspective, she isn't necessarily come
to the full conclusion yet. Mhm. So, if
she's writing it from an early
perspective and it's, you know, very
emotional, like questioning, I don't
know why he moves me. Like, he's
supposed to be just a guy, like just a
man. I've had many men before in very
many ways. He's just one more.
I'm not taking that as like this is
entirely her conclusion, right?
Especially if it's early on. So, I get
how it is. I I understand the innuendo
and and how they're like in a subtle way
like bringing him down, but you could
see how an early encounter with many
people would be like, "Who is this guy?"
Like I thought he was just a man. Like
at some point they have to come to the
conclusion that he's God. Like even
Peter like eventually he's like, "You're
the Christ." And and he's told, you
know, flesh and blood has not revealed
this unto you. It's, you know, this is
revealed to you by the Holy Spirit. But
he had to come to that conclusion. It
wasn't his immediate like he wasn't just
like he saw Jesus and he was like, "Dude
is God." He had to grow into that
understanding. So, I don't know. I'm
just looking at this like I don't know
what perspective this is from. I don't
know where it's at in the story line,
but I wouldn't immediately just read it
like
necessarily
cutting down knowing the whole story
line. Yeah, I think from memory it was
coming late a little bit later into the
story line. Okay. It wasn't like right
at the beginning, but So it's like
towards the end. I think it was like
toward middle end. Okay. M I find this
terribly um like offensive. I don't like
it. Why not? It's weird for me to to
just hear it like it I don't know. It's
it's
it's like
a just twisting of I I think everybody
kind of in this world I don't know how
many people probably could say I know
nothing about God. I don't know anything
about him whatsoever. like, you know,
people have an idea of what Jesus means
and who he was and, you know, that he
was God and and here it is. It's just
like tinkering with that. I'm just
thinking if you were like as a
character, if you were her then coming
from that perspective, yeah. No, I get
what you're saying. Questioning like who
is this guy? Like is he a man or I I get
what you're saying. I'm just saying to
me it's like hard for me to watch and
listen. Like I'm cringing. I don't want
to listen to this, you know? Yeah. Mhm.
So, um I agree with you, Keith. Um I,
you know, it could be it could be
interpreted both ways, I think,
depending on, like you said, where it's
at the storyline, but just want to
reiterate John 1 1-5. In the beginning
was the word, and the word was with God.
The word was God. He was in the
beginning with God, and all things are
made through him. And without him,
nothing was made that was made. In him
was life, and life was the light of men.
And the light shines in the darkness,
and darkness did not comprehend it. So,
we believe Jesus is God, right? So, to
continue on at the lyrics, she says,
"Should I bring him down? Should I
scream and shout? Should I speak of
love? Let my feelings out. I never
thought I'd come to this. What's it all
about?" Don't you think it's rather
funny I should be in this position? I'm
the one who's always been so calm, so
cool. No lover's fool, running every
show. He scares me so. I never thought
I'd come to this. What is what's it all
about? Yet, if he said he loved me, I'd
be lost. I'd be frightened. I couldn't
cope. Just couldn't cope. I'd turn my
head. I'd back away. I wouldn't want to
know. He scares me so. I want him so. I
love him so. Yeah. They're definitely
sexualizing that, right? Yeah. Like, as
if that's what the relationship was all
about. And it wasn't. Right. Not a
redemption that she was loving him. has
no nothing to do with the the other.
Yeah. Yeah. So, I just find it very
blasphemous. And this was a lot of the
criticism that came out back in the day
from conservative Christians. This one
is this is where it gets a little bit
weird. This is Herod and just a little.
This is Herod and they portray him as uh
I don't know. He doesn't really have a
palace. He's just standing on a platform
near the water which he calls his
swimming pool. And um you know I I don't
know if I have anything else to say.
Just watch it and let me know what you
think. It's nice wig on the right.
Cripples raising from the dead.
Now I understand your God.
Huh? You are the Christ. You're the
great Jesus Christ.
Prove to me that you're divine. Change
my water into wine. That's all you need.
Do then I'll know it's all
true. Come on, King of the
Jews. Jesus, you just won't believe the
hit you've made around here. You are all
we talk about. You are the wonder of the
year. Oh, what a pity if it's all a lie.
Still, I'm sure that you can rock the
cynics if you
try. So if you are the Christ, yes, the
great Jesus
Christ, prove to me that you're no fool,
walk across my swimming pool. You know,
this kind of puts into perspective um
Cynthia wasn't wrong that apparently
this musical is looking like the gayest
thing on earth. If this is what they
wear in the ' 90s or ' 80s, I don't want
to know what they're going to wear in
2025.
You know, it just looks to me like a
bunch of people that almost look like
drag queens. There's dudes in there
looking like chicks and it's very
strange and um not even the looks, just
the whole concept of the song and
everything and it's hard to watch. Yeah,
there is a lot of people who come at
Christianity and religion from that
perspective though. They're like, we
just want to see the signs. We just want
to see the miracles. I mean, even in
Jesus day in John chapter 6, you know,
he said that you just come to me for a
sign. Mhm.
And he, you know, he's like he had just
done one the day before. Mhm. And show
us a sign. No. In John chapter 6 is
feeding the 5,000. And the very next
day, people come to him and religious
leaders come to him and they're like,
show us a sign. It's like Jesus just fed
5,000 people. Mhm. Yeah. How do you not
like this is the only miracle recorded
in all four gospels? Oh, I'm Yeah, I'm
I'm shocked more people don't like, you
know, get after this. But when this came
out, you know, it's it's probably like
in the 70s ' 80s just people didn't
care. you know, they're coming off of a
conservative 60s or 50s and it's like
the 70s just was this weird drugfueled
like do whatever you want kind of a
lifestyle. What was the criticism back
then when this was released? There were
multiple things like M Mary Magdalene's
portrayal like looking like she was in
love with Jesus. But like how was the
reception? How did people receive this
the public? Yeah. Oh well I mean Jesus
Christ Superstar this movie I would say
is almost on par with um what is the
other one the passion of the Christ
millions of people have seen this movie
millions I mean even on you can see here
Fand Fandango movie clips there are
secular movie outlet and they're sharing
this kind of stuff you know um and that
the some of the clips still have
millions of views on YouTube too cuz
around that time uh Martin Scorsesei
came out with the movie the last
temptation of Jesus or the last
temptation of Christ. And that movie was
received really poorly. It was uh it
wasn't allowed to be shown in France and
and uh some parts of Europe. Many states
in the US did not allowed their many uh
theater owners did not allow that movie
to be played and it wasn't even
portrayed in a blasphemous way. It was
like kind of I guess it was his his
perspective on the whole gospel and it
wasn't like mockery or anything or a
musical like that. So I'm surprised that
this was wasn't received you know as
badly as the last temptation of Christ
was right it is the it is an attitude
that many people take like Jesus is they
treat it like a genie you know he's
there to give me what I want it's kind
of all a cart Christianity you know I
have these things I want I have these
things I need you know so make it happen
but that's not really what we need
Yeah, I'm just thinking back on how when
I watched this with my mom, we were both
genuine, you know, like I just picked it
up from the library and was like, "Oh,
it's a movie about Jesus. I'm interested
in it." My mom was like, "I've heard of
that before or she had seen it before.
Let's watch it." None of us were like,
"Oh, we think this is a mockery to
Jesus." It just didn't even register.
Um, and so I want to say that
because, you know, there's many movies,
TV shows out there about Jesus. And just
because it's about Jesus doesn't mean
it's a correct portrayal of Jesus and
something we can safely watch and assume
that it's not going to affect us
spiritually, right? That it's teaching
the truth. Exactly. And that's the same
reason why we did two documentaries talk
and multiple videos talking about the
chosen. And that's a very controversial
topic, but I'd encourage anybody in in
who who's watching this video, go go go
check out those documentaries because
this might be a bit more explicit, but
The Chosen is so subtle that it will
easily just like plant a seed in your
brain and you don't know that it did,
but it's planting seeds of doubt. We
know what what like you know comic
strips and cartoons that are making fun
of political leaders and stuff you know
really kind of got its legs in the in
the French Revolution and they started
making like fun of the political leaders
and stuff and they were able to change
the mindset of the people in that day.
Yeah. simply using humor and and so you
know you you wonder like what does this
do even if like people who you know have
a little understanding of who Jesus was
and you watch this and like ah whatever
it's funny and stuff like this but but
what kind of seed did that just plant in
your mind that down the road it's like
you just kind of like you you don't have
the reverence for God after something
like this. Yep. I agree. Yeah. And the
people that want to make
it, I guess if you look at where they're
coming from in Christianity should tell
you a lot about where this is going. And
you know, hey, this is a call to all
Christians, right? This if this is what
the world get exposed to like, you know,
Jesus is just this like, you know,
magician and he's out there doing this
and that. It means that we need to do a
better job at going out there and really
portraying the love of God and and
sharing those things with people because
we can we can easily put the right
picture out when people meet Christians
and they go, "Wow, I you know, I didn't
really want to think about Jesus Christ,
but I really like this Christian guy
over here and and now I'm going to I'm
going to be open to it." I think you can
kind of do your own part to rewrite in
people's minds what it means to be
Christian. Mhm. Well, obviously before
Jesus goes to Caiaphas and to Pilate and
all of them, he is found in the Garden
of
Gethsemane. And it's so wild. Again, I
watched this movie. I remember all of
these scenes and I did not in my young
brain pick up on the kind of Jesus that
was being portrayed. Partially because I
wasn't really a Christian yet. Partially
because this is what movies do to you.
Check this out. And we will play three
different clips from the scene and then
we'll have the lyrics and uh it's it's
really
sad. I only want to
say if there is a
way take this cup away from
me for I don't want to taste its
poison. Feel it burn me. I have changed.
I'm not as
sure as when we
started. Then I was
inspired.
Now I'm sad and
tired.
Listen, surely I've
exceeded
expectations. Tried for three years.
seems like
30. Could you ask much from any other
man?
Jesus is starting to doubt.
Starting to question, should I really be
doing this? Now, it's interesting how
much they're blending scripture with
with what they're saying, right? Like
Jesus did say, Lord, if it was possible,
take this cup from me. But then he says,
"But thy will, not my will be done."
Right. Didn't hear that last part in
there, did you? No. No. Yeah. And and
this is really the true test that Jesus
actually went through, right? I mean,
this was his agony of of like accepting
the road that God was sending him on.
And um you know, actually Jesus
volunteered for this. Yes. To happen.
That's kind of an important part. Yeah.
He said, "Lord, this is really hard.
Like if this if it's possible." So in
other words, like if there's any other
way, but but he was never not willing.
Never. He was never not willing. Yeah.
The any other way should give us a clue
like how agonizing. I still want the
outcome.
Mhm. Exactly. I still want to save. I
still, you know, so if there's another
way we can save him. Yeah. Yeah. But it
wasn't like I just want to eject out of
this thing altogether, you know. Yeah.
So let's continue. Um, and uh, it just
gets more and more interesting.
Lord,
why should I die? Oh, why should I
die? Can you show me now that I would
not be killed in vain?
Show me just a little of your omniresent
brain. Show me there's a reason for you
wanting me to
[Music]
die. Kane on where and how, but not so
hard on
why. All right.
[Music]
[Applause]
Just watch me
die.
See, see how
[Music]
that's messed up. It's really It's
really that God's just insens
insensitive and just wants to end his
life. M yeah, I was telling Filipe it's
like God's just like, "Oh man, those
humans messed up. Kick him. Kick you out
of heaven. You go fix that mess over
there whether you like it or not and
you're going to die and I'm going to
watch you die as like a tyrant." Well,
the man emphasized that's Mary that was
emphasized in the Mary song is really
coming out heavily now because it makes
it look like there is no pre-existence
of Jesus. He is just a man that God has
chosen to pour out his wrath on, right?
And watch He has no clue what the plan
of salvation is about. No sense of the
atonement. Like nothing. It's true.
Like, why am I supposed to die? Just And
then he gets angry at God. He's like
shouting and screaming at God.
Chose me for this thing. I didn't ask
for it. I don't want it. And you got to
remember that this is a song and songs
stick. They do.
The danger of one of these songs getting
stuck in your it's almost inevitable
that at some point a song is going to be
stuck in your mind. Yesterday I'm just
like no making food for the next day and
this just this song keeps popping up and
like I've been singing that in my head
the whole day. At some point I get gets
annoying. But that's not even the worst
part is the message of the song. It just
gets stuck in there. Yeah. That you
don't even know how to differentiate
truth from error. Yeah, it's true. As a
parent, Keith, you can probably speak to
this as well. Um, you know, if you had a
choice between your child dying for
something and you dying, what would you
choose? Yeah, I die. I would die. I
don't even have to think about it. I
mean, it would just be like a split
second. So the idea that God was, you
know, experiencing this death when he
has the power to stop it and he doesn't
because he has to let this thing play
out. I don't think we talk enough about
the the just pain that God went through
to watch his son do this. And and yeah,
this just plants this little like
insensitive seed that it's just like,
"Oh, all you want to do is watch me die.
All you want to do is watch me die."
It's like, "No, man. God God was like I
I don't think there was a sound made in
heaven. I bet. Yeah. And the and the
father son
dynamic is just using human language so
we can relate because it's really just
like chosen roles. Yeah. I mean they're
both co-eternal. Mhm. So it's it's you
think of somebody you've been with for a
really long time,
you know, and that bond that's formed.
Mhm. We understand it in the father the
father or mother child relationship and
it's like yeah I would do that but for
them it's it's probably a little
different. It it has to be when when
when um they said a thousand years is
like a day to God and a day is like a
thousand years. I mean even 3 days away
from him was probably felt like an
eternity. Somebody you've been with for
eternity. Never seen them die. Still to
this day I think people don't think
about this component as well. No
celestial being has died but Jesus.
None. That's right. No Satan's angels,
no nothing. Jesus is the only one that
laid down his life. And I love it that
he says, "I laid down my life and I took
up my life again." Like if you were
dead, how do you take up your own life?
Like it's amazing that that's why you're
just like, "Okay, it this is God."
Period. Yeah. Let's look at the last
part here. This is toward the end of the
song where he basically comes to God
again and he's like, "Okay, I guess I'll
give my life for the cause of humanity."
I
was inspired.
[Music]
No, I'm
sad and
[Music]
tired. After
all, I've tried for 3
years. Seems like
90. Why then am I scared to
finish what I started?
What you
started I didn't start
it
God. Thy will is
hard but you
hold every
card. I will drink your cup of
poison.
Lead me to your
cross and break
me.
Bleed me. Beat me. Kill
me. Take me
now before I change my mind.
He's basically accusing God again, angry
at God, and he's just like, "Well, I
didn't choose this. You chose this
again." Like this tyrant kind of God.
But Scotty, you already brought up this
verse, John 10:17 and 18. Therefore, my
father loves me because I lay down my
life that I may take it again. No one
takes it from me, but I lay it down of
myself. I have power to lay it down and
have power to take it again. This
command I've received from my father.
It's Jesus' own choice. Jesus is God
never forced him to do anything, right?
No. And then like he it makes it look
like there's no loving relationship
between the two of them, but John 5:20
says, "For the father loves the son and
shows him all things that he himself
does." They have a beautiful
relationship. They're a fatherson
relationship. And and you know, you were
asking Keith, would you lay down your
life for your child? And you would too.
Like how could we as humans say that?
But then they portray God, right? as
like like now humans are better than
God. And I think every human would say
that. I don't care if you believe in God
or not. You you would it's just a human
thing that you'd be like if my choice
was between me living and my kids living
then take me out. Absolutely. And so
yeah, if you don't even have to believe
in God to have that kind of mentality,
you know, what a slam on God to be like,
you're the one that make this happen.
Fine, I'm just going to let you kill me.
Then why don't you kill me now or I'm
going to change my mind. Like that's
just I'm gonna change my mind.
Absolutely dig on God. Yeah. 100%. Yeah.
And then um you know in this book, Sex,
Drugs, Rock and Roll, and Musicals,
Scott Miller also writes about this
other part which there's a there's a
song that I just remember they're
singing what's the buzz? Like what's the
buzz about? You know, like what's
happening? But then he says the Roman
soldiers arrest him, Jesus. As the
drunken apostles wake, they sing,
"What's the buzz?" The crow like a play
on words. The crowd that gathers uses
the melody from the moneylenders in the
temple as they taunt Jesus and demand he
be taken to Caiaphas who questions him
and declares him guilty. So now the
disciples are also drunk. I think I
think from memory this was after the
Lord's supper. So I guess during the
Lord's supper they got drunk and then
it's like what's the buzz? What's the
buzz? The Bible never talks about the
disciples getting drunk and the Bible
calls being drunk a really bad thing. So
I highly doubt that Jesus was sitting
there at the Lord's supper and and they
were getting drunk.
So, um, here's a clip where Judas, he
hangs himself and interestingly, right
after or soon after this, Judas comes
down from heaven on a cross in white and
he presents himself to Jesus to question
him a little bit more and basically be
sarcastic at him. But he died, so did he
just come back from heaven on a cross?
And this is the weird thing like he is
shown to be almost like
resurrected. The resurrection of Jesus
never happened in this movie. Left that
out. Maybe purposely. Very purposeful. I
think
[Music]
there's the cross. So wait a minute.
This is Judas coming back to life. Is it
a cross or a star? Well, it's a star,
but it keeps going down. If it goes all
the way down to the chain, it's a cross.
Is that Judas? Is that Judas? Yeah. So
Judas was resurrected. Well, but they
never show Jesus resurrected. Well, they
never say he was resurrected, but he's
coming out from heaven. And I know it's
like a star, but then if it goes all the
way down to the chain, it makes it a
cross. Oh, yeah. Yeah, I get what you're
saying. I just I'm sitting there
wondering the chain is just a necessary
tool to him. I guess Yeah. Either way,
he's coming down from heaven dressed in
white. I guarantee you the thought
process of that was to to reveal a
cross. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, maybe I mean, why why do
we need a thought process about bringing
Judas from heaven after after he hangs
himself in the first place? Yeah. And
Jesus doesn't get a resurrection. Yeah.
And and and it's like, you know, we we
kind of talked about Judas potentially
not being in heaven, right? So, you
know, they're putting they're putting a
statement here. The guy that denied God
or Jesus is coming down in white. Yeah.
Yeah. And then so there's some of the
lyrics because so after this he goes
into this whole dance like 70s style
with all these women around him dressed
in the 70s clothing and uh he sings
this. Every time I look at you I don't
understand. This is towards Jesus. Why
you let the things you did get so out of
hand? You'd have managed better if you'd
had it planned. Why' you choose such a
backward time in such a strange land? I
if you'd come today you could have
reached a whole nation. Israel in 4 BC
had no mass communication. Don't. So
he's talking about like the 70s, right?
Don't you get me wrong. I only want to
know Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ, who are
you? What have you sacrificed? Jesus
Christ, superstar. Do you think you're
what they say you are? Could Muhammad
move a mountain? Or was that just PR?
Did you mean to die like that? Was that
a mistake? Or did you know your messy
death would be a record breaker? Jesus
Christ. Jesus Christ. Who are you? What
have you sacrificed? Jesus Christ
superstar. Do you think what you they
say you are? So they show this whole
movie, this whole musical and in the end
they just bombard you with these
questionful questions. And this stab is
like you know did you have a plan? There
was a plan of salvation for the creation
of man. Exactly. That and and
and you know that after so many days
Jesus goes to heaven. I don't I don't
know what the time frame he comes down,
but but then I it's a ludicrous idea
just totally. But to think that if he
did go to heaven now there's no answers,
right? You don't know what the purpose
was and you're going to God is God is
clueless. Yeah. Yeah. To couldn't tell
him what was going on. to say you have
no plan when God basically in the very
first verse of the Bible when you read
that in Hebrew that verse in the very
first 10 words or whatever that is tells
the plan of salvation please tell me
that that wasn't purposeful the whole
Hebrew like everything about what they
do their alphabet their just their whole
language and everything yeah deals with
the plan of salvation the entire Bible
which has chosen which cultures and
nations are going to rule the world and
which ones are going to fall. You can't
guess that thing. God tells the
beginning from the end. And I'm super
offended that they even would put that
out there. Just wait until Cynthia Revo
plays that character. And
then he and then the questioning person
finds himself in heaven questioning the
very plan that saves him. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Supposedly, and he doesn't believe
it. Yeah. Like that doesn't even make
any sense. Like you're saying, Scotty,
in in Genesis, in the beginning, you see
the plan of of salvation. And then look
at Revelation, the last book of the
Bible. All who dwell on the earth will
worship him whose names have not been
written in a book of the life of the
lamb. The lamb according to John the
Baptist is Jesus. So this is Jesus slain
from the foundation of the world. Yeah.
The plan was always there. doesn't mean
that he was or died in the at the
foundation or what at the creation of
the world. It means that's when this
happened. It's like from the beginning
Jesus had a plan to die for us. Yeah.
And then eventually he came as we see in
the gospels. So this was always there.
But you know um I I think it's it's it's
very sad that this is going on still.
Jesus Christ Superstar and I watched it
thought I was Christian. I know I'm sure
many people watched it that maybe
thought this was like some Christian
movie and many seeds have been planted
millions and millions of them and then
they had this ongoing musical and now
Cynthia Arivo is playing Jesus which I
personally think is very offensive no
matter who wants to play Jesus in that
role. But I see Jesus very differently.
Isaiah 53:5 says, "But he was wounded
for our transgressions. He was bruised
for our iniquities. The chastisement of
our peace was upon him. And by his
stripes, we were healed. Jesus is is our
best friend. He is our brother. He's our
savior. And the amount of absolute
torture physical, mental, spiritual, he
had to go through that no other human
being had to go through. He I mean and
that's not that's not even the the
that's not even the only thing that he's
done for us but besides the cross which
is the best thing he's ever decided to
do for us but also to come down from
heaven in the first place. Right. Right.
Like leaving everything behind like you
said I think Keith who said it like
leaving everything behind to come to
this earth that's like like um a king
becoming a cockroach willingly. Yeah. It
it it's amazes me that people support
this kind of thing when it's like,
"Yeah, he's taking your punishment." So
So I guess I would throw the question
back out there like, "Satan, what have
you done? Oh, did you leave your place
to come down here and die for your
people?" Or no, all this bad stuff
that's happened is because of you. and
the one that's trying to fix it and
solve it and offer you a an opportunity
to have your slate wiped clean, that
your sins be as scarlet and they'll be
as white as snow because of what Jesus
did for us. That you're going to make
fun of. Yeah. So, I I look, I think the
best thing to do is to avoid support on
this kind of a thing all the way around.
Don't even go watch it. Yeah. And I
mean, some somebody asked me this once.
Uh if God is real, why is do why is
there so much suffering in the world? I
mean if God didn't let suffering happen,
nobody would hate Satan. Nobody would
hate Satan enough to appreciate the
sacrifice. This is very true actually,
right? So if um I mean if even after you
know for the viewers at home after you
watch this show pick up your Bible and
learn who the true Jesus is because this
is this was made in such a way that even
in even if it is a mockery even if it
was made to you know not be taken
serious it's the seed is still planted
just like the Holy Spirit plants the the
good seed the devil can also plant the
bad seed. That's right. We need to know
who our Jesus is. Yeah. Right. Because
otherwise we're just taken away. What if
you know um the the question Scotty
asked, how many people watched this and
turned their lives around for Christ and
how many people watched this and turned
away from Christ? It's easy to just
listen to a song like this and start
having the doubts that Jesus was having.
It's like, wait, no, he has a valid
point. Does he though? I mean, once you
get to know the Jesus of the Bible, you
know, everything is just clear as day.
There's nothing in in the Bible that was
not answered, not a question that was
not answered. So, we need to know who
Jesus is. I I hope that this episode
will be a warning to our other genuine
Christian believers, brothers and
sisters, because you know, Satan is a
deceiver. And it was it says in the
Bible that if it were possible even the
very elect would be deceived. So we know
that that Christianity his version of it
and true biblical Christianity will be
so close and we can see it all around us
that when we think we're in God's field
in God's will or whatever that is that
it's actually deception. And and I know
this sounds maybe disheartening for some
people because they might be like,
"Well, how am I supposed to know the
truth?" Thy word is truth. The Bible
says, right? Jesus is the word as John 1
says, and the word is truth. And so, as
long as we are in the word, I believe we
have the promise of God that he will
show us the truth and he will help us
not to be deceived. But if we're not in
the word, that's not going to happen.
And you know it always I always am
inspired when I hear about the dark ages
when people didn't have the Bible right
the Bible was forbidden for Christians
to read and pe Protestants were willing
to lay down their life lay down their
life so that they could share the word
others could have the word and they
could have the word and they could
worship God in spirit and truth
according to the light that they were
given. So but I want to wrap it up with
this verse right here. Romans 1:16-17.
For I am not ashamed of the gospel of
Christ, the good news of Jesus. For it
is the power of God to salvation, for
everyone who believes, for the Jew first
and also for the Greek. For in the
righteousness of God is revealed from
faith to faith. As it is written, the
just shall live by faith.
I I I love that verse in the end of re
Revelation that says, you know, no eye
hath seen, no ear has heard that the
things that I have planned for those
that love me. And you know, it it's like
God is God is recognizing we we we went
through a rough time down here. This
was, you know, just a nightmare for many
people to live this existence of life.
And he's offering us a way, a way out of
this. Why would you ever hate on that?
Why would you ever, you know, and and I
I go back to the same thing like if if
if you just took your wife or your
spouse, would you want a movie made
where somebody is laughing, poking fun,
mocking your family? What if it was you?
Would you like someone to do that to
you? Right? No, I wouldn't. And so, you
know, this kind of a thing, it's like
even in just a funny way, somebody
going, "Oh, it's like this is going to
change what I believe about him." I'm
still like I wouldn't even give this two
seconds of my time. Amen. If you like
this video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comments
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]